I am so excited and it's officially
official we are making it beep to all
the voices but to all the boys I've
loved before sequel is officially in
production with some new faces right now
in the sequel we're so excited
just days after Netflix revealed that
Jordan Fisher would be playing Laura
jeans other love interest John Ambrose
are you ready he found out that 13
reasons why star Ross Butler is joining
the cast - on the ascent of the top of a
sequel but what's happening yeah that's
Butler and the Internet's boyfriend nois
Antonio dancing it out between takes
that was very sorry
Butler will play Trevor pike Santa Neos
characters BFF producer Matt Kaplan
explained the casting choice to ET
saying quote his real-life friendship
with Noah brings a natural chemistry and
great rapport to the set and we can't
wait for fans to see this friendship
play out on screen
Santonio will of course be back as peter
Kavinsky ok what happened you fainted
Peters a bit of an egotistical guy but
he also liked underneath the surface of
him looking like a jock he actually
really carries in he's respectful and
he's sensitive
he's a teddy bear I hate the surface
based on Jenny Hans best-selling to all
the boys trilogy the first flick kicked
off when Lara jeans love letters she'd
written to her crushes including John
and Peter were secretly mailed out the
letters are out
by the end of the first movie Laura Jean
and Peter made their relationship
official but in the second book John
shakes things up and the story revolves
around a love triangle with Laura Jean
John and Peter know and I have really
amazing chemistry and I think large and
asked to have really amazing chemistry
with John Ambrose as well et caught up
with Lana Condor in March and she dished
on heading back to set for the sequel
I'm so excited I'm just beyond excited
we were starting shooting it really soon
and gushed over reuniting with Santonio
it's really really amazing he's so
talented and he's an amazing actor and
and we've always gotten along very well
so I couldn't have asked for a better
co-star
[Music]